hey guys now most of you know the
amazing story of David and
Goliath I mean you hear it everywhere
because it inspires people to also
overcome the challenges in their lives
and I mean who cannot be inspired by
David an underdog who everybody thought
would not be able to defeat
Goliath Shepherd's boy he came and did
it when everyone in Israel was afraid I
mean they had Fierce Warriors strong
guys but they were afraid and then Here
Comes David
Fearless think about this even his own
father did not include David at first
when he let all his other Sons stand in
front of Samuel when Samuel would choose
the new king from Jesse's
Sons listen to this 1 Samuel
16:10 and Jesse made Seven of his sons
PA before Samuel and Samuel said to
Jesse the Lord has not chosen these then
Samuel said to Jesse are all your sons
here and he said there remains yet the
youngest but behold he is keeping the
sheep and Samuel said to Jesse send and
get him for we will not sit down till he
comes here and he sent and brought him
in now he was Ruddy and had beautiful
eyes and was handsome and the Lord said
arise anoint him for this is
he so here God chose David to become the
king of Israel the Future King but Soul
was still King and in this time the army
of the Philistines they came to have war
with Israel and with them came a
champion their champion the Giant
Goliath and this is what happened 1
Samuel
17:3 and the Philistines stood on the
mountain on the one side and Israel
stood on the mountain on the other side
with a valley between them and there
came out from the camp of the
Philistines a champion named Goliath of
goth whose height was six cubits and a
span now how tall is that that's around
9 ft and 10 in that's around 3 m that's
huge imagine you stand in front of a
mountain man giant 3 m tall he wasn't
just tall but he was he was very strong
I'll get to that in a minute I want to
mention something interesting here he
was probably from the tribe from the
people of the anakim if you watch my
video on the Nephilim the Mighty Man of
all the Giants you would know this but
if you haven't go check it out it's it's
a very interesting series that I'm
covering we also know that Goliath had
Brothers other Giants and here's the
thing today you have a lot of people who
who grow tall and there are medical
problems you know and usually they're
not always strong but these Giants were
strong listen to this verse 5 says he
had a helmet of bronze on his head and
he was armed with a coat of M and the
weight of the coat was 5,000 shekels of
bronze and he had bronze armor on his
leg legs and a javelin of bronze slung
between his shoulders the shaft of his
spear was like a Weaver's beam and his
Spear's head weighed 600 shekels of
iron his bronze armor alone was 125 lb
56 kg That's Heavy I mean you can try to
put it on and just walk a little bit but
put that on Walk For Miles towards an
enemy and then have the energy to still
taunt them and ready for a
battle you won't be able to do that
verse 8 he stood and shouted to the
rangs of
Israel why have you come out to draw up
for battle am I not a Philistine and are
you not Servants of Soul choose a man
for yourselves and let him come down to
me if he is able to fight with me and
kill me then we will be your servants
but if I Prevail against him and kill
him then you shall be our servants and
serve us and the Philistines said I
defied the ranks of Israel this day give
me a man that we may fight together when
Saul and all Israel heard these words of
the Philistine they were dismayed and
greatly
afraid so this probably wasn't just a
normal giant even this guy was fierce
almost looked like he had blood in his
eyes ready just to to kill and devour
these little men like straw because the
whole of Israel they were afraid of this
giant I mean they must have had powerful
Champions as well strong men but even
they were afraid at
Goliath because verse 24 says all the
men of Israel when they saw the man fled
from him and were much
afraid now you know what happened next
David without
fear came against Goliath and you know
how that ended for him but there's a lot
of things that people don't know about
the story or that they miss and I want
to share that with you but before I
explain that to you you need to
understand something else first and that
is that this was not just a battle
between a man and a giant between Israel
and the Philistines this was a battle
between good and evil the battle that
all all men and women face in their
lives listen to this verse 42 and when
the Philistine looked and saw David he
disdained him for he was but a youth
Ruddy and handsome in appearance and the
Philistines said to David am I a dog
that you come to me with sticks and the
Philistine cursed David by his Gods so
Goliath cursed him with his gods and
this is important because we know know
that these gods were demons remember
Deuteronomy 32:17 says they sacrificed
to Demons that were no Gods to gods they
had never
known and Paul also says in 1
Corinthians 10: 19 what do I imply then
that food offered to Idols is anything
or that an idol is anything no I imply
that what pagans sacrifice they offer to
Demons
and not to God I do not want you to be
participants with
demons go watch the series that I
started on the truths that all men need
to know about life in that video series
I explain my experience with demons
growing up and after that also the
history of how men started to worship
demons thinking they are gods and how
religion started before the flood and
after the flood now let's move forward
verse 44 the Philistines said to David
come to me and I will give your flesh to
the birds of the air and to the beasts
of the field then David said to the
Philistine you come to me with a sword
and with a spear and with a javelin but
I come to you in the name of the Lord of
hosts the god of the armies of Israel
whom you have defied you see David did
not fight through the flesh with his own
power he fought with God God's power
that was in him through the spirit you
see he did not have self-confidence he
had God confidence he said in verse 46
this day the Lord will deliver you into
my hand and I will strike you down and
cut off your head and I will give the
dead bodies of the host of the
Philistines this day to the birds of the
air and to the wild beasts of the earth
that all the Earth may know know that
there is a God in Israel and that all
this assembly may know that the Lord
saves not with sword and
spear for the battle is the Lord's and
he will give you into our
hand you see David had no fear he knew
God was with him that God's spirit is on
him guiding his own will his own
emotions his own intellect his
soul you know that's the difference we
talked about this on my channel a lot
between self-confidence and God
confidence now David knew that God's
spirit is on him giving him the strength
and that is why he had no fear how do we
know this how do we know this that David
acted through the
spirit it happened back when Samuel
anointed David to be king listen to this
chapter 16 : 13 then Samuel took the
Horn of oil and anointed him in the
midst of his brothers and the spirit of
the Lord rushed upon David from that day
forward now this is amazing because not
only did David act through the power of
the Holy Spirit not only that but he ran
towards goath
towards the thing God wanted him to face
this is amazing normal men even the most
powerful men in the army of Israel they
looked at Goliath and they were
afraid David had no fear because of
God's spread in him not only that but
he he ran towards him to fight how many
times have you buckled because of fear
the challenges the
obstacles the problems in your own life
how many times have you B ult out of
fear because you acted in your flesh and
not through the power of the spirit
God's spirit that is in you verse 48
says when the Philistine arose and came
and draw near to meet David David ran
quickly toward the battle line to meet
the Philistine most people miss this
without fear because he was in the
spirit acting in the spirit he ran
towards his en enemy to face him quickly
Fearless
man how amazing is our
God verse 49 and David put his hand in
his bag and took out a stone and slung
it and struck the Philistine on his
forehead the stone sank into his
forehead and he fell on his face to the
ground so David prevailed over the
Philistine with a sling and with a stone
and struck the Philistine and killed him
there was no sword in the hand of David
then David ran and stood over the
Philistine and took his sword and Drew
it out of its sheath and killed him and
cut off his head with it when the
Philistines saw that their Champion was
dead they
fled wow this is amazing you know you
might not face a giant Philistine but
you will face many challenges in your
life many obstacles and you cannot run
from it neither can you fear it you
cannot face it through your own power
through the flesh you need to face it
with the power of the Holy Spirit who is
in you if you are a real child of God so
many people run away from their problems
their challenges their Giants because of
fear and this is important to understand
because if you do that those problems
will just stay there those challenges
will stay there not only that they might
might grow and there will be more
problems that's added to it so later on
in life you'll just be carrying a heavy
heavy load so big that you'll Buckle
under the pressure you need to handle
your GS the moment they surface David
also said in psalm
56:3 when I am afraid I put my trust in
you in God whose word I Praise In God I
trust I shall not be afraid what can
flesh do to me the moment you fear you
need to understand that that is the
moment that you're not trusting God
that's when you are starting to act in
the flesh through your own power and not
in the spirit and you have no excuses
because today since 2,000 years ago
after Jesus Christ all reborn Believers
when we accept Jesus Christ as our Lord
and savior he gives us his spirit so you
have the spirit of God in you to help
you to overcome any challenge in your
life Acts
2:38 and Peter said to them repent and
be baptized every one of you in in the
name of Jesus Christ for the Forgiveness
of your sins and listen to this and you
will not maybe not probably you will
receive the gift of the Holy Spirit you
need to understand this when you are
declared righteous when you come to
repentance when you truly accept Jesus
Christ as Lord and Savior when he makes
you a new creation he gives you his
Spirit you are sealed by the SP Spirit
Ephesians 1:13 in him you also when you
heard the word of Truth The Gospel of
your salvation and believed in him were
sealed with the promised holy spirit so
how do you do this how do you overcome
challenges in your life you need to be
weak weak in yourself to such a degree
where you deny yourself your own selfish
desires your own self-determining will
it needs to be under the power of God he
needs to sit on your throne not you it
is only when you come to the end of
yourself your own power oh me me me it
is only when you come to the end of that
life where you surrender to the power of
God where he can start to work through
you let me tell you when you do that
when you let the Holy Spirit work
through you and guide your soul out
there in the world world everything you
do everything you say everything you do
then nothing will be impossible for you
to accomplish God's plan and purpose for
your life because he will give you what
you need to accomplish it and he will
give you the power through the holy
spirit that is in you and the spirit of
God who is in you is not afraid 2
Timothy 1:7 says for God gave us a
spirit not of fear but of power and love
and selfcontrol
Satan on the other hand he uses a spirit
of fear and
uncertainty in my new book called bold
Pursuit a 90-day devotional for men
seeking the heart of God I explained it
this way he tries to convince us that
life is too overwhelming that we don't
have the emotional strength to deal with
our challenges he amplifies our negative
emotions so that they drown out
everything else and leave us feeling
hopeless no matter how dark things seem
there is always
light David said the Lord is my light
and my salvation whom should I fear the
lord is the defense of my life Whom
Shall I dread psalm
27:1
wow this is amazing you know David was
just a man just like you and
me but God called him a man after my own
heart why because he lived within God's
will he did what God wanted him to do he
lived according to the spirit so let me
ask you why if you are a child of the
Living God god with his spirit in you
who wants to help you who wants to guide
you who wants to give you strength to
overcome challenges who wants to lead
you in everything you do why do you want
to carry on and fight the challenges in
your own power you a small human being
so little and Tiny temporary one day
you're here the next you will be gone
dead we are so small but the god of the
universe wants to help you he spirit is
in you and it is the same spirit that
Rose Jesus from the
grave if the spirit of him who raised
Jesus from the dead dwells in you he who
raised Christ Jesus from the dead will
also give life to your mortal bodies
through his Spirit who dwells in you now
if you want to learn more how to grow
deeper and deeper in Christ to become
stronger a mature Christian to learn
what it means to abide in him to fully
surrender oh there is so much that we as
his children can learn you know the
Bible says that we have already received
all spiritual blessings do you even know
what they
are it is time to grow we cannot stay
babies in Christ infants in Christ we
need to grow so that we can become
stronger if you want to grow and please
get my new book I'll add the information
for you indid description and you can
also watch these videos here and I'll
see you there and always remember that
God loves you and I love you
too life is
short so please do not waste
yours bye
guys